any advice you'd give for someone who's
watching this that wants to get into the
real estate [ __ ] because i do feel like
it's like a weird time where
the properties cost more than ever but
the interest rates are lower than ever
so it's like it's like a do i get it now
do i wait
man i could talk about real estate stuff
forever but basically i would start with
reading books um there's this uh
platform called bigger pockets my wife
loves it she goes on there basically um
anything you can think of like any topic
they've tackled it they've done books on
it they've done podcasts all that uh
that's a great start for me i just
started with rich dad poor dad which was
like shout out to yeah i love rich dad
poor dad yeah i read that [ __ ] in high
school yeah it was just a change in my
mindset it helped me understand what the
difference between assets and
liabilities were right like cars
even though they're dope they're
depreciating liabilities they cost you
money everybody where assets are things
that grow in value so i make a song i
put it out
right it's while i'm sleeping it's
generating money while i'm sleeping my
car is costing me money right because
it's going down down so um trying to
figure out how to develop more assets
which is one of the reasons we moved
start buying property start investing in
things that will grow
um so that was like a starter kit for my
mentality then it was you know other
books and so i would say start there too
um
for real estate stuff it's like this my
my wife has a really good um example she
says
if you want to buy property there's
basically a scale of comfort and
cost
so if the more willing you are to be
uncomfortable the better the price right
so that's the sliding scale and so
you're like oh i want to get a really
well priced you know property it's like
all right you might be in the hood for
three years you know what i'm saying
or you're like no i want to live in the
best of my eyes you might be in a small
spot that's right or a small spot or
whatever it is so you have to weigh that
out and for me and my wife it was like
yo
we down we down to thug it out for a
couple years and really just like put
our head down and buy property and you
know not you know
not ball out you know i'm saying so
we did that and it's been incredible for
us so
that sliding scale will help you
determine what you want to do two is
like if you can if you know how to rehab
or like fix these joints up or you have
people you know contractors that's
really the end is you got to buy a
crappy property and fix it fix it up and
that's how you get good prices and
that's how you add value fire you know
and you gotta be ready to go it's like
when deals come across the table you're
gonna have to
how's your guys's credit scores fire
it's perfect perfect crazy i got like
over 800 or something how like was that
something that's been consistent for you
or did you like have to handle some [ __ ]
to get it up to that ah bro you know
what i'm i'm weird but i just been good
with money like since i was young so
when i was in my 20s i was i was doing
these shows i was selling merch online
doing just kind of entrepreneurial
and um
i had like i'd take the money i make i
pull up these spreadsheets on on google
and i just be like alright this money
i'm going to give here this is for
saving i even created a marriage account
when i was single
it's crazy i take a little slice of
every check and i just like put some in
there i'm gonna have to get married one
day because i was like one day i want to
get married and i don't want to go in
here like very very expensive or a ring
or whatever and i was just like yo i
don't want to be
i don't want to be out here like oh now
that i'm ready to go so you're a single
man just budgeting [ __ ] out on google
spreadsheets crazy i don't even know
where this came from bro i just was a
responsible young man so by the time i
met the girl i was ready to get married
i was like oh i got 20 grand saved so i
can go get this ring or whatever i need
to do i was just ready to go you're a
[ __ ] special guy man weird yeah very
strange but you know it served me well